and so since you you unlocked our hearts
we want to give you this key to New York
City to hang up to hang up near many of
the other mayor Eric Adams presenting
the key to the city to composer Andrew
Lloyd Webber on Friday
tomorrow night Lloyd Webber's signature
production comes to a close after a
record run of 35 years The Majestic
Theater will host the final performance
of Phantom of the Opera the musical is a
critical and Commercial Blockbuster and
it reset the standard for Broadway
Productions Elaine quijano gives us one
last glimpse of the Phantom before the
curtain comes down
[Music]
when Phantom of the Opera debuted at
Broadway's Majestic Theater in 1988
American audiences had never seen
anything like it
with a soaring score by Andrew Lloyd
Webber and gloriously Gothic staging the
story centers on a disfigured mask
wearing musical genius living in the
Paris Opera House who becomes
dangerously obsessed with a young
soprano Adam Feldman is the longtime
theater critic of Time Out New York it
was a very lavish very Sumptuous
production with a huge Orchestra a huge
cast huge costumes and sets so as an
audience member coming into it even if
you didn't necessarily even speak the
language you could still get a wonderful
theatrical experience out of it the show
won seven Tony Awards including best
musical I thought it would run forever
and I'm sad about it
[Music]
Howard mcgillin performed as the Phantom
longer than any other actor in the
show's
more than 2500 performances over the
course of 10 years
some music
it's a challenge to play this role
because it's it's physically and
emotionally very very intense there's a
lot of physical climbing of ladders
backstage and dropping through trap
doors but then there's this emotional
intensity of the role that is exhausting
but thrilling at the same time that
intensity mesmerized theater goers in
its 35-year New York run Phantom sold
some 20 million tickets earning more
than a billion dollars but when the
pandemic shut Broadway down the show
never fully recovered after its
reopening in 2021 ticket sales waned
that along with Rising production costs
prompted The Producers to announce its
closure this has kind of been my home
away from home it's a Bittersweet moment
for Alan lampell who fell in love with
Phantom more than three and a half
decades ago
head electrician has kept a close watch
over the lights and effects from day one
through more than thirteen thousand
shows six days a week after all these
years how do you feel seeing the
production
it's sad it's sad to see it go
it's been such a big part of my life
what do you think you're going to miss
taking care of the show it really is a
fine piece of art and I've been blessed
to
have it
under my in my hands
for all these years grief and gratitude
at having played a role in Broadway
history it changed my life it changed my
career I'll forever have this as a part
of my little Legacy on Broadway for CBS
Saturday morning Elaine quijano New York
[Applause]
how amazing the electrician I talked to
has been running the show there since
day one time yeah so many people behind
the scenes that make everything happen
that we all watch and see yeah but those
people out front I tell you they're the
ones who just Electrify Us in the
audience couldn't do it without the
folks funds that's exactly it definitely